Los humanos tenemos un potencial extraordinario para la bondad,
pero también un inmenso poder para hacer daño.
Cualquier herramienta puede usarse para construir o para destruir.
Todo depende de nuestra motivación.
Por lo tanto, es aún más importante
promover una motivación altruista que una egoísta.
De hecho, ahora, en nuestra época enfrentamos muchos desafíos.
Podrían ser desafíos personales.
Nuestra propia mente puede ser la mejor amiga o la peor enemiga.
Existen también desafíos sociales:
la pobreza en medio de la abundancia, las desigualdades, los conflictos, la injusticia.
Y luego nuevos desafíos inesperados.
Hace 10 000 años, había cerca de 5 millones de seres humanos en la Tierra.
Cualquier cosa que hicieran,
la resiliencia de la Tierra pronto sanaba la actividad humana.
Luego de las revoluciones industrial y tecnológica,
ya no es lo mismo.
Ahora somos el principal agente de impacto en la Tierra.
Entramos en el Antropoceno, la era de los seres humanos.
En cierta forma, si quisiéramos continuar este crecimiento sin fin,
este uso ilimitado de recursos materiales,
es como si este hombre dijera
--lo oí de un ex jefe de Estado, no voy a decir quién--
"Hace 5 años, estábamos al borde del precipicio.
Hoy hemos dado un gran paso adelante".
Esta frontera es la que los científicos definieron
como límites planetarios.
Dentro de esos límites, pueden darse una serie de factores.
Todavía podemos prosperar, la humanidad aún puede prosperar durante 150 000 años
si mantenemos la misma estabilidad del clima
como en el Holoceno durante los últimos 10 000 años.
Pero esto depende de que elijamos una simplicidad voluntaria,
crecer cualitativamente, no cuantitativamente.
En 1900, como pueden ver, estábamos bien dentro de los límites de seguridad.
En 1950, vino la gran aceleración.
Contengan la respiración, no demasiado, e imaginen lo que viene después.
Ahora hemos rebasado ampliamente algunos de los límites planetarios.
Tomemos por ejemplo la biodiversidad, al ritmo actual,
en 2050, un 30 % de las especies terrestres habrá desaparecido.
Aunque mantengamos su ADN refrigerado, no será reversible.
Por eso estoy allí sentado
frente a un glaciar a 7000 metros (21 000 pies) en Bután.
En el Tercer Polo, 2000 glaciares se están derritiendo más rápido que el Ártico.
¿Qué podemos hacer en esta situación?
Bueno, por compleja que sea en lo político, económico, científico,
la cuestión del medio ambiente
simplemente se reduce a una cuestión de altruismo versus egoísmo.
Soy marxista, de Groucho.
(Risas)
Groucho Marx dijo: "¿Por qué deberían importarme las generaciones futuras?
¿Qué han hecho ellas por mí?"
(Risas)
Por desgracia, he oído al multimillonario Steve Forbes,
en Fox News, diciendo exactamente lo mismo, pero en serio.
Consultado sobre la crecida de los océanos,
dijo: "Me parece absurdo cambiar mi comportamiento de hoy
por algo que va a pasar dentro de cien años".
Si no te importan las generaciones futuras,
adelante.
Por eso, uno de los desafíos actuales
es conciliar 3 escalas de tiempo:
el corto plazo de la economía,
las altas y bajas del mercado de valores, el balance de fin de año;
el término medio de la calidad de vida,
cuál es la calidad de vida en cada momento, cada 10 años, cada 20 años,
y el largo plazo del medio ambiente.
Cuando los ambientalistas hablan con los economistas,
se produce un diálogo esquizofrénico, completamente incoherente.
No hablan el mismo idioma.
Ahora, en los últimos 10 años, fui por todo el mundo;
me reuní con economistas, científicos, neurocientíficos, ambientalistas,
filósofos, pensadores, en el Himalaya, en todos lados.
Me parece que solo hay un concepto
que puede conciliar esas 3 escalas de tiempo.
Simplemente, tener más consideración por los demás.
Al tener más consideración por el otro, tendrán una economía del cuidado,
en la que las finanzas estén al servicio de la sociedad
y no la sociedad al servicio de las finanzas.
No jugarán en el casino
los recursos que las personas les han encomendado.
Si uno tiene más consideración por el otro,
se asegurará de remediar la desigualdad,
de aportar algún tipo de bienestar a la sociedad,
en la educación, en el lugar de trabajo.
De lo contrario, en ser la nación más poderosa y rica
donde todos son pobres, ¿cuál es la idea?
Y si uno tiene más consideración por el otro,
no saqueará el planeta que tenemos;
al ritmo actual, no tenemos 3 planetas para continuar de esa manera.
Por eso la pregunta
es, bien, el altruismo es la respuesta, no es novedad,
pero ¿puede ser una solución real, pragmática?
Ante todo, ¿existe
el verdadero altruismo, o somos egoístas?
Algunos filósofos pensaban que éramos irremediablemente egoístas.
Pero, ¿realmente todos somos bribones?
Eso es una buena noticia, ¿no?
Muchos filósofos, como Hobbes, lo han dicho.
Pero no todos parecen bribones.
¿Es el hombre el lobo del hombre?
Este tipo no parece tan malo.
Es uno de mis amigos en Tíbet.
Es muy amable.
Nos encanta la cooperación.
No hay dicha más grande que trabajar juntos, ¿no?
Y no solo para los humanos.
Luego, claro, está la lucha por la vida,
la supervivencia del más apto, el darwinismo social.
Pero en la evolución, la cooperación --aunque existe la competencia, claro--
la cooperación tiene que ser mucho más creativa
para ir a mayores niveles de complejidad.
Somos súper cooperadores y deberíamos ir más allá.
Y ahora, además de eso, la calidad en las relaciones humanas.
La OCDE hizo una encuesta con 10 factores, incluyendo ingresos, todo.
Lo primero que las personas señalan como importante para su felicidad,
es la calidad de las relaciones sociales.
No solo en humanos.
Miren esas bisabuelas.
Y esta idea de que si profundizamos en nuestro interior,
somos irremediablemente egoístas,
esto es ciencia de sillón.
No hay ni un solo estudio sociológico,
ni psicológico, que haya mostrado eso.
Más bien, lo contrario.
Mi amigo, Daniel Batson, pasó toda una vida
poniendo a las personas en el laboratorio en situaciones muy complejas.
Claro, a veces somos egoístas, y algunas personas más que otras.
Pero él encontró que sistemáticamente, sin importar nada,
hay un número significativo de personas
que se comportan de manera altruista, sin importar nada.
Si uno ve a alguien profundamente herido, sufriendo mucho,
quiere ayudarlo por angustia empática;
uno no puede soportarlo, es mejor ayudar que seguir mirando a esa persona.
Probamos todo eso y, al final, él dijo que claramente podemos ser altruistas.
Eso es una buena noticia.
Y aún más, debemos mirar la banalidad de la bondad.
Miren esto.
Al salir no diremos: "Eso es tan agradable.
No hubo puñetazos mientras la masa pensaba en el altruismo".
No, no se espera eso, ¿no es así?
De haber una pelea a puñetazos, hablaríamos de eso durante meses.
La banalidad de la bondad es algo que no llama la atención,
pero existe.
Veamos esto.
Algunos psicólogos dijeron
cuando les conté que realizo 140 proyectos humanitarios en el Himalaya,
eso me da mucha alegría,
dijeron: "Ya veo, trabajas por el resplandor cálido [warm glow].
Eso no es altruista. Simplemente te sientes bien".
¿Piensan que este tipo, al saltar frente al tren,
pensó "Me voy a sentir genial cuando esto termine"?
(Risas)
Pero eso no es todo.
Cuando lo entrevistaron dijo:
"No tenía alternativa, tenía que saltar, claro".
No tiene alternativa. Comportamiento automático. No es egoísta ni altruista.
¿No hay alternativa?
Bueno, por supuesto, este muchacho no iba a pensar media hora:
"¿Debería darle la mano? ¿Debería no hacerlo?"
Lo hizo. Había una alternativa, pero obvia, inmediata.
Y luego, también, allí él tenía una opción.
(Risas)
Hay personas que no tenían opción, como el pastor André Trocmé y su esposa,
y todo el pueblo de Le Chambon-sur-Lignon en Francia.
En toda la Segunda Guerra Mundial, salvaron a 3500 judíos,
les dieron refugio, los llevaron a Suiza,
contra todo pronóstico, arriesgando su vida y la de su familia.
El altruismo existe.
¿Qué es el altruismo?
Es el deseo de que el otro sea feliz y encuentre la causa de la felicidad.
La empatía es la resonancia afectiva o la resonancia cognitiva que les dice:
esta persona está alegre, esta persona sufre.
Pero la empatía por sí sola no es suficiente.
Si uno sigue enfrentado el sufrimiento,
es posible padecer angustia empática, agotamiento,
y se requiere una esfera mayor de bondad.
Con Tania Singer del Instituto Max Planck, de Leipzig,
demostramos que las redes cerebrales para la empatía y la bondad son diferentes.
Todo está bien hecho,
lo tenemos por la evolución, el cuidado materno, el amor de los padres,
pero tenemos que extenderlo.
Puede extenderse incluso a otras especies.
Si queremos una sociedad más altruista, necesitamos 2 cosas:
cambio individual y cambio social.
¿Es posible el cambio individual?
Dos mil años de estudio contemplativo dijeron que sí, que lo es.
Y 15 años colaborando con la neurociencia y la epigenética
dijeron que sí, que nuestro cerebro cambia si se entrena en el altruismo.
Pasé 120 horas en una máquina de resonancia magnética.
Esa fue la primera vez que estuve 2 horas y media.
El resultado se ha publicado en muchos trabajos científicos.
Demuestra, sin ambages, que hay un cambio estructural
y funcional en el cerebro si se entrena el amor altruista.
Solo para darles una idea:
a la izquierda el meditador descansa,
hace meditación de compasión, ven la actividad,
y luego el grupo de control descansa, no ocurre nada,
sin meditación, no ocurre nada.
No han sido entrenados.
¿Se necesitan 50 000 horas de meditación? No.
Cuatro semanas, 20 minutos por día de meditación afectiva, consciente,
ya genera un cambio estructural en el cerebro comparado con un grupo de control.
Son solo 20 minutos al día, durante 4 semanas.
Incluso con niños en edad preescolar; Richard Davidson lo hizo en Madison.
Un programa de 8 semanas: gratitud, amabilidad, cooperación, respiración consciente.
Podrían decir: "Son solo niños en edad preescolar".
Miren después de 8 semanas,
el comportamiento pro-social, es esa línea azul.
Y luego viene la última prueba científica, la prueba de las pegatinas.
Antes, se debe determinar por cada niño el mejor amigo de la clase,
el menos favorito, un niño desconocido, y el niño enfermo,
y tienen que asignar pegatinas.
Antes de la intervención, le dan la mayor parte a su mejor amigo.
Niños de 4, 5 años, 20 minutos, 3 veces por semana.
Después de la intervención, no más discriminación:
la misma cantidad de pegatinas al mejor amigo y al niño menos favorito.
Eso es algo que debemos hacer en todas las escuelas del mundo.
¿Cómo sigue esto?
(Aplausos)
Cuando el Dalai Lama se enteró, le dijo a Richard Davidson:
"Ve a 10 escuelas, 100 escuelas, a la ONU, al mundo entero".
¿Cómo sigue?
El cambio individual es posible.
¿Tenemos que esperar que entre a la raza humana un gen altruista?
Eso llevará 50 000 años, demasiado para el medio ambiente.
Afortunadamente, existe la evolución de la cultura.
La cultura, como se ha demostrado, produce cambios más rápido que los genes.
Eso es una buena noticia.
La actitud hacia la guerra ha cambiado drásticamente en los últimos años.
El cambio individual y cultural se modelan mutuamente,
y sí, podemos lograr una sociedad más altruista.
¿Cómo seguimos?
Yo volveré a Oriente.
Ahora tratamos 100 000 pacientes al año en nuestros proyectos.
Tenemos 25 000 niños en la escuela, 4 % por encima.
Algunas personas dicen: "Bueno, tus cosas funcionan en la práctica,
pero ¿funciona en la teoría?"
Siempre hay desviación positiva.
Así que yo también volveré a mi ermita
para encontrar los recursos internos para servir mejor a los demás.
Pero a nivel más global, ¿qué podemos hacer?
Necesitamos 3 cosas.
Aumento de la cooperación:
Aprendizaje cooperativo en la escuela en vez de aprendizaje competitivo;
cooperación incondicional dentro de las empresas,
puede existir cierta competencia entre empresas, pero no dentro.
Necesitamos armonía sustentable. Me encanta este término.
Ya no crecimiento sustentable.
Armonía sustentable significa que ahora reduciremos la desigualdad.
En el futuro, haremos más con menos,
y seguiremos creciendo cualitativamente, no cuantitativamente.
Necesitamos la economía del cuidado.
El Homo economicus no puede ocuparse de la pobreza en medio de la abundancia,
no puede hacer frente al problema de los bienes comunes
de la atmósfera, de los océanos.
Necesitamos una economía del cuidado.
Si uno dice que la economía debería ser compasiva,
dicen: "Ese no es nuestro trabajo".
Pero si uno dice que no les importa, eso es mal visto.
Necesitamos compromiso local, y responsabilidad global.
Necesitamos ampliar el altruismo al otro 1,6 millón de especies.
Los seres sensibles son co-ciudadanos en este mundo.
Tenemos que atrevernos al altruismo.
Larga vida a la revolución altruista.
Viva la revolución del altruismo.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.